what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the nine pillars also
known as the hashida the most powerful
demon slayers
in the demon slayer core after the
massive positive response that we got on
our last demon slayer video which
discussed all the different breath
styles and their special powers I don't
think I have another choice but to make
more demon slayer content I mean I do
have another choice but I absolutely
love demon slayers so why wouldn't I
make more especially when so many of you
wonderful space cowboys and space
cowgirls have asked me to do just that
in episode 21 of the demon slayer anime
we finally got to meet the fearsome
pillars and in this video for your
convenience I will be breaking down all
of their characteristics and backstories
as well as their unique powers and
abilities I hope that you will find it
useful to have all of this info right
here in one place so let's get to it
if you enjoyed the Demon Slayer content
on this channel and you'd like to see
more please leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification valve you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest anime news and
updates and finally this video will
contain some manga spoilers about
character backstories and their powers
since not all of them have been
introduced properly in the anime as of
the making of this video however this
video will not contain spoilers about
what happens to these characters later
on in the story we are sticking strictly
to their backstories personality and
powers the nine pillars are the elite
warriors of the demon slayer core and
the most powerful of all the demon
Slayers for example we've all seen that
our boys tangey Roseanna tzu and inosuke
have some serious skills and significant
strength and mezu cochon is also an
impressive warrior but during the fight
against rui one of the weakest of the 12
demon moons tan Jiro Mitsuko inosuke and
zenit su almost died and they almost
certainly would have died if give the
water pillar hadn't shown up and not
only that gears show up he was able to
take
in just one shot which gives us a good
idea about how powerful the pillars
actually are when compared to the lower
rank demon slayers like Tangier oh and
the crew so since I already mentioned gu
and since he was the first of the
pillars that was introduced to us in the
series let's kick things off with him GU
Tomioka makes his appearance in Episode
one of the anime and chapter one of the
manga he was the demon slayer who tried
to kill him as Zuko after she became a
demon but he decided to let her live
when he saw how committed she was to
protecting her human brother ton zero
even though she had already become a
demon do you sense that there was
something different about mezu CO and he
took a big risk by letting her live gu
decided to lead tangelo and mezu code to
his former masters Sakon ji Oroku ducky
and he wrote a letter to her Okazaki
asking him to train tan 0 to become a
Demon Slayer from what we know so far
gu seems to be one of the strongest
demon Slayers in the entire demon slayer
core including the pillars
however he often feels cold and distant
in terms of his personality we find out
later that this is due to his tragic
past much liked on zero-g use family was
slain by demons when he was young but
Ghia survived because he was protected
by his sister this is probably why
despite his Demon Slayer instincts he
ultimately decided to spare Nezha KO
after seeing her bond with pan Jiro
after his family was killed by demons he
was alone in the world and he went
through a lot of hardship when he was 13
years old gu met a boy named sabi toe
and they became friends they would both
train in the breadth of water
swordsmanship style under 2nd judoka da
ki and they would go on to take the
final selection exam together during the
exam he was injured by a demon and his
life was actually saved by sabi toe gu
lost consciousness and when he woke up
he realized that he had survived the
exam but his friend sabado had not sabi
too died during the selection exam it
isn't hard to see why gu is so cold and
distant most of the time when we
consider everything he had to go through
if you would like to know more about gu
specific breath style and all his
fighting powers and abilities along with
the abilities of the other pillars and
demon Slayers you can check out my all
15 battle style
in demon slayer explained video where I
go into great detail about all the
different unique powers that the demon
slayers used to defeat the demons I will
link that video down in the description
and also at the end of this video next
up let's talk about one of the best and
also scariest waifu's that this series
has to offer and of course I'm talking
about shinobu kocho I'll also tie-in her
sister canonical show since the two of
them have the same backstory and kana is
a very important part of she know whose
life Shinobu is the insect pillar while
kana is the flower pillar when they were
young their parents were slaughtered by
demons before their very eyes but the
current stone pillar Goma himejima
arrived just in time to save Shinobu and
kunai both sisters swore to become demon
Slayers so that they could fight back
against the monsters that kill their
parents the two sisters are great
characters with impressive skill and
intellect but there is still something a
bit off-putting about Shinobu in
particular while kana has seems to be
very kind
Shinobu definitely has a sadistic side
as seen during the epic battle against
rui and the spider family nevertheless
the sisters appear to be kind people
overall they saved soo Yuri from slavery
by buying her from her master and then
training her to become a Demon Slayer on
the butterfly estate soory later took
the same final selection exam as tan
Jiro and Zenit soo and she was the only
woman who passed that specific test she
Nabucco chose breath of insect style is
a derivative of the flower breath style
and by extension of the breath of water
style because she lacks brute physical
strength she no booze fighting style
focuses on combining stabs thrusts
shallow cuts and slashes with poison
that way she can take down an opponent
without cutting him down with physically
powerful slashes again for more detail
on her unique powers and abilities check
out the every battle style video link in
the description now let's talk about
Guillaume a himejima the stone pillar of
the demon slayer core this man is
absolutely massive and he actually
stands at over seven feet tall
Yomi is the strong silent type so we
don't know a whole lot about his
personality but we do know that he is
blind and that he
appears to cry a lot for unspecified
reasons before he became a pillar yo Mei
was raised inside a temple along with
nine other orphan children the area
around the temple was known for demon
attacks and one day one of the orphaned
children crossed paths with a demon in
order to save his own life the orphan
offered to lead the demon to the other
nine orphans in exchange for his own
life
yo Mei tried to lead all the children to
safety but because he was blind and
perceived as weak by the others most of
the children didn't trust yo mate to
protect them and they all ran off on
their own sadly this was a mistake as
all the children were killed by the
demon except for Co the only one who
actually stayed with Yomi once the demon
eventually caught up to the oh man sigh
oh he managed to injured Yomi by cutting
him across the forehead and he still has
that scar today but yo Mei was able to
counter-attack and defeat the demon by
beating him over and over again until
the Sun came up
yo man was then falsely accused of
killing the children himself since the
demons body had evaporated but
thankfully he was saved by yokatta sama
and recruited into the demon slayer core
he eventually became the stone pillar of
the demon slayer core and in Chapter one
three four of the manga tangier owned in
Osaka state that Yomi is the strongest
of all the demon Slayers right now
including the pillars when he fights
Chioma uses chained axes and a spiked
flail instead of a sword then we have
the flame pillar kyo judo rank oku who
is known for his commitment to honor and
duty as a warrior he is the son of shin
doo doo dangu co the former flame pillar
and he succeeded his father to that
position after his father stepped down
JoJo's father is demanding and harsh but
Jojo has a good heart and he is
committed to protecting those who happen
to be weaker than himself this is a
value that his mother instilled in him
when he was still a child and he
believes that the fact that he was
blessed with strength means that he has
the duty to help those who were not born
with as much strength as him as his
pillar name suggests Kyoto uses the
breath of flame style which allows him
to infuse his attacks with powerful
flames that can deal an incredible
amount of damage to opponents and they
can even scorch the terrain all around
him next up we have the kawaii killer
Mitsu recon Rajee
the love pillar of the demon slayer core
she was born with unnatural strength and
strange pink hair and these features
made her an outcast in fact she was seen
as so strange that she couldn't be
married off to anyone she tried her best
to fit in at first and to hide her
unique features but she eventually
decided that she would embrace her
eccentricities she joined the Demon
Slayer Corps and rolls all the way to
the status of a pillar she decided that
she would not marry anyone who was
weaker than her but this leaves her
options quite limited because as a
pillar she is one of the strongest
characters in the series meatsuit his
fighting style involves a wide variety
of acrobatic moves that other people
cannot hope to duplicate and she is
known for naming her breath forms with
reference to kitties such as lovely
kitty shower and kitty paw loved breeze
for more on all her known moves and
abilities you can check out the
previously mentioned battle styles video
now let's talk about tengan you Sooey
the sound pillar he is a muscular guy
with eccentric tendencies he wants
everything he does to be noticed and
admired by others and he proudly states
that he loves to be flamboyant he has at
times been shown to be so focused on his
missions that he neglects to act with
courtesy towards other people such as
when he tried to kidnap a bunch of girls
from the Butterfly estate so that he
could use them for his mission but
nevertheless he grew up in a shinobi
family so he is trained as a shinobi
which makes him extremely fast and an
incredibly powerful warrior his breath
of sound is a style that is derived from
the breath of thunder similar to
echolocation yuzu is capable of
deconstructing an opponent's movements
into bass sounds analyzing the sounds
and identifying openings based on those
sounds he can then go on to exploit
those openings with devastating
consequences next up we have Orochimaru
wait wait I mean open eye Goro the snake
pillar open eye is ruthless to anyone
who breaks the Demon Slayer laws and he
is a very strict teacher he deeply
distrust tangier Onizuka because he
considers Naza cos continued existence
as a demon to be a blatant violation of
the Demon Slayer laws he is in love with
meatsuit
the love pillar and who can blame the
guy sadly Obon I does not have the
confidence to confess his feelings to
meet suti so she seems to be largely
oblivious to the true nature of his
feelings Obon I uses the breath of
serpent style a derivative of the breath
of water which emphasizes fast
serpentine movements then we have the
wind pillar sauna me Sheena tsugawa sana
me is covered in scars across his face
and chest and much like our boy inosuke
sonic he can be very hot-blooded and
impulsive however you could argue that
sodomy takes these traits to another
level as he seems to lack empathy and is
always itching for a fight
sanim he comes from a broken home his
father was abusive and he was forced to
kill his own mother after she turned
into a demon and began killing her own
children sanam ii was traumatized by
this experience and he set out on a
reckless demon hunting spree since he
didn't even know about Nichiren blades
he would seek out demons find a way to
restrain them and then wait for the Sun
to come out and destroy them that way he
could have easily been killed while
using this reckless strategy but asana
me later acknowledges he managed to
survive due to a heavy dose of luck sana
me possesses Medici a rare blood type
that the demons find especially
desirable and intoxicating the scent of
his blood is so intoxicating that it is
able to distract demons and this gives
Sunna me an opening to take them out
sodomy eventually met a demon slayer by
the name of Musashi Kakuma no and this
Demon Slayer persuaded sonna me to join
the Demon Slayer Corps san amis breath
of wind style is believed to be
distantly related to inosuke breath of
the beast style so presumably breath of
wind also enhances the user's sense of
touch and of course breath of wind
allows sana me to infuse his attacks
with various wind based powers including
whirl winds and tornadoes finally we
have the mist pillar machito taquito he
is short with long black and green hair
and he is known for having his head in
the clouds most of the time he is always
wandering off and he seems unable to
focus on any one single thing at a time
with that said when we chat of faces a
serious battle he shows himself to be a
fierce and
powerful fighter like many children in
the world of demon slayer Mucha too lost
his parents at a very young age and he
and his twin brother Yuichiro were left
to fend on their own one night they were
attacked by a demon and Yuichiro lost
his arm defending his brother we too
know flew into a rage and he destroyed
the demon with every tool that he could
find and he continued to destroy him
again and again until the Sun came up
once the demon was finally defeated mu
Ichiro returned to the house to tend to
his brother but ultimately his brother
died as a result of the encounter with
the demon this traumatic experience led
to mu Ichiro losing his memories and
taking on some of the personality traits
of his brother
Yuichiro mu Ichiro's breath of mists
style is a derivative of the breath of
wind and his swordsmanship style is
highly technical with clear similarities
to Japanese martial arts like a idol and
those are the nine demon Slayers who are
the current pillars at the beginning of
the Demon Slayer series along with them
we've also met some former pillars
including Kyoto Rango whose father
Shintaro the former flame pillar and
[ __ ] of Iwo Jima and Sakon G or
Okazaki
the former Thunder and water pillars
respectively
jiguro is senators master and Sakon ji
is of course the mentor of Tangier Ong
you
the former Thunder pillar jiguro is a
short man who had two pupils one of his
pupils could only learn the first form
of the breath of thunder and the other
could learn all except the first jiguro
was loving but always expected the best
from his students he wouldn't accept
them giving up or giving anything less
than their maximum effort however he was
also understanding of his students
shortcomings he even told Zenit Suh that
if he could only learn one form of the
breath of Thunder style then he should
work hard until he becomes the master of
that one form and of course a kanji or
Okazaki is the Tengu mask-wearing former
water pillar he has trained many pupils
over the years and he lost some of them
to the final selection test he is slow
to warm to other people but he shows a
love for his students that is deep and
profound the moment where tan Jiro
returns from the test a new Roku ducky
drops everything to run after him and
hug him is one of the highlights of this
series for me the moment itself is so
simple but the situation just has so
much weight to it and it is definitely
one of the most powerful moments in the
series I also found it amazing to learn
that in order to get the Demon Slayer
Corps to agree to letting musical live
both eurocode Aki and GU agreed to
commit seppuku
if Natsu ko ever ended up hurting an
innocent person that is how much faith
these two have in tangier oh and Natsuko
and I find that truly heartwarming and
that is it for our video on all 9
pillars and their powers for more
specific info on everyone's breath style
feel free to check out the old 15 battle
styles explained video link in the
description please let me know down in
the comments who is your favorite out of
the 9 pillars and why personally I'm a
pretty big fan of ghee you I love the
fact that despite being common cold on
the outside he showed such trust in
tangier oh and mezu coal that he was
willing to place his own life on the
line for them that is really powerful
especially when we look back to give you
in Episode one and chapter one and how
all of this started if you enjoyed the
Demon Slayer content on this channel you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell a big
shout out to my friend Excel Yan for
helping me with this video with the
research and also with the visual
editing working with him has been a
pleasure please check out his channel
link in the description and show him
some love he just made a new video on
Angel Beats which is an anime that I
adore and I really enjoyed the video so
definitely check him out I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime
upper patrons for supporting our work
and making our videos possible a special
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius and on hell crews on Epic
thank you to all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace in
grata alone Adam
Maddy Mac makoto-kun and Keylong and
finally at the pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness
a tier reserved only for legends
massive thank you to Reagan Harrison and
Lord naksan or disciples of Lord we go
himself if you enjoy our videos and you
think they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon link
in the description even a single dollar
will give you access to our exclusive
patron only discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us bass cowboys
[Music]